[Musique]
en déça le plus grand port de la mer
noire au lieu de la première révolution
russe
ici en 1905
sur cet escalier le fameux escalier
potemkine 2000 insurgés furent massacrés
par les policiers ce tarif
pour peu que leur voyage les entraîne
sur les bords de la mer noire et
touristes français ne manque pas de
remonter les marches au moins une fois
nous sommes installés là pour les
attendre et pour les rencontrer pour une
fois nous avons renoncé à notre regard
pour emprunter le leur vous ne
connaîtrez de l'esa de l'union
soviétique que leurs impressions de huit
jours 15 mois ou un mois de vacances
leur première rencontre se sont souvent
leur voiture qui les suscitent
adam connaître un peu le russe on lui
pose les questions techniques très
compliqué elle répond comme elle peut
on lui demande le prix 1600 roubles une
volga la voiture soviétique la plus
courante août 5611
[Musique]
ils ont choisi comme cette parisienne de
voyager sans souci une guide de l'hymne
touristes l' agence de voyages
soviétique est venu les accueillir à
l'aéroport
elle sera pour quelques jours leur
campagne de premier add
on lit aussi le livre y en a dix qui
déclare emprunt se livrent les personnes
ont fait les frais le montage élections
surtout les retraités
[Musique]
cette option
n'a plus ténue allait venir bousculer
ses
habitudes
que je paie 10 kg de plus
bingo j'ai dit c'est pas beaucoup
cinquante kilos 800
si vous avez des enfants vous ne ferez
pas la queue
[Musique]
une édition les gleek
merighetti le service ne sais pas mais
ses centrales à seissan travailler le
lendemain
à lécousse il ya trois fonctionnaires
c'est formidable que je crois que
c'était une année une entreprise
personnelle ça nos biens les personnels
auront chez vous
personnel chez vous tout les
gouvernements tout est parfaitement
cliquer oui
c'est différent c'est le passé
la foule compacte des grandes plages de
vesa où de nombreux soviétique viennent
du nord passer leurs vacances et
épargner aux touristes étrangers
ils ont leurs plages privées un peu à
l'écart la plage de l'île touristes
trop lyonnais rencontré ce jour là avait
décidé de chercher plus loin un coin
plus tranquille encore nous les avons
suivis jusqu'à la porte de la ville
qu'ils n'auraient dû franchir d'après
leur emploi du temps officiel que le
lendemain on peut se rendre à kiev
avec la voiture a sauté mais choukaj
mpla à jour je vais te couper le
souffle un
morceau d'os
comme un héros des séries et après ce
qu'il veut il veut il veut la crasse
il me reste
qu'à
limoges ne peut pas sortir de la ville
non non il fallait à la plage à 500 m
viola porte on la voit très bien la port
près on est sorti des bordelais
bien que nous
alors retour en ville nous leur avons
demandé de nous parler de leur voyage
les a priori question
messieurs vous avez l'air enchanté notre
voyage aux murs en santé c'est beaucoup
dire un on est plutôt déçu parce que
comme je le disais tout à l'heure c'est
plutôt un voyage d'étude qu'un voyage
touristique un voyage de vacances
il ya quelques paysages intéressant
malheureusement c'est gâché par beaucoup
de brimades manque de confort
malgré tout une certaine méfiance qui
est vis-à-vis de nous qu'on soit
français ou simplement n'importe
quand les brimades
comment parler de brimades des extraits
bien brimades vos jambes les rapports
des éclats de la police ne sont pas
toujours très très
et pourquoi courtois motoriste lui peut
se considérer comme un genre d'interdît
séjour dans la campagne il doit rester
dans la ville se cantonnait la ville et
il ne peut absolument pas en sortir et
si on vous demandait de définir la
situation de à le touriste français
justement est une espèce de deux vaches
ont lu très tous et de tous et franz oc
dollars actuellement rouler tous les
prétextes sont bons on ne peut acheter
certaines choses qu'en dollars on avait
prétendu qu'on peut acheter du caviar
avec nos bons repas qu'on utiliserait
pas ournac 100 grammes par personne et
il reste il faut absolument acheter
uniquement en devises étrangères et les
gens même le maître d'hôtel le garçon
qui sert à une espèce de consignes il
doit tirer du dollar dit doit-il et du
dollar ou du vivant aux touristes
d'origine ukrainienne xvi léger et de
retrouver vos origines jusqu'au bout oui
j'ai essayé d'aller au village de mon
père ça a été naturellement
interdite je crois quand même qu'on peut
tenter l'expérience on peut aller sur la
route on peut passer j'ai un français
qui à prayssac qui retournait qu'avec
lui-même trois jours dans le village
de ses parents chez de leur famille moi
personnellement on a refusé par contre
ce qui se fait beaucoup et ce qui doit
induire jusque au maule touristes
français en erreur c'est que si les
personnes qui veulent voir la famille
doivent recevoir à l'hôtel en payant
donc leur séjour de la famille à l'hôtel
payant les repas en payant le voyage il
déplace le losc s'est dit alors qu'ils
habitent la campagne que j'ai je suis je
vous ai proposé de commercer oui halo
legends où ils veulent acheter votre
chemise les gens se précipitent sur nos
lunettes c'est le service technique de
l'étranger les lunettes de soleil on
aurait pu en vendre tant qu'on voulait
le terrain du camping de dessin est en
cours d'installation tous les touristes
étrangers sont donc logé dans l'un des
deux hôtels in tourisme de la ville ils
ont obligatoirement acheter en france
avant leur départ des coupons donnant
droit à la chambre et au repas quand ils
sont sortis de l'hôtel le premier jour
pour faire un tour sous les arbres de la
rue couche qu'il ils ont été sollicités
immédiatement par le petit membre des
trafics installés à demeure autour de
chaque côté line touristes de leurs
la vente des icônes et le trafic de
devises sont pas si l'ambiance de dix
ans de prison
je n'ai nous proposer aussi de changer
nos devises
au double du cours normal
par exemple
mais c'est celle de l'argent
font partie des photographes c'est le
plus court
bon
double coin
au lieu de 30
115 au lieu de
la presse en france le double des
enfants
ça vaut pas le coup
et dans un camp de pionnier que nous
avons rencontré la promotion sortante de
l'école centrale
l'une de ces remarquables colonie de
vacances où 80 % environ des enfants
soviétique passe un mois chaque année
[Musique]
si vous revenez en urs reviendrez-vous
en voyage organisé
protégez difficile de régler autrement
on ya droit
vous pensez qu'il est difficile de
revenir autrement s'il ya des gens des
gens qui viennent habituellement m'enfin
ils ont à peu près les mêmes contraintes
que ceux qui paient d'embrayage
qu'elle convertit doivent unis doivent
donner leur itinéraire à l'avancé d'une
touriste enfin parfois subir un guide
les touristes
par conséquent individuellement ou en
groupe avait pas la même chose
et vous êtes ingénieur par exemple ou
visiter des usines oui on a visité des
usines et vous demander à le faire des
départs pardon vous demandez alferi nous
avons en été forcé de le faire puisque
c'est un voyage d'étude de fin d'études
on est donc forcé visité un certain
nombre d' usine or neuf et de la même
façon on avait proposé un certain nombre
d'usinés visiter aussi biennale ingrate
qu'à kiev cas où des sacs à moscou
line touristes ont accepté certaines a
refusé d'autres en fin de compte je
crois qu'il ya une confusion qui s'est
établi sur le nom de l'école d'autres
sortaient l'école centrale il se fait
visiter que des centrales de viser une
centrale à leningrad que pour les autres
visité une centrale à kiev un avis près
une troisième à moscou ça c'est pas
grave pour marquer et des choses
intéressantes dans les centrales réagir
j'ai visité une centrale nucléaire par
exemple ça on n'a pas obtenu l'accord de
visiter j'avais demandé à visiter la
centrale de doute non au nord de moscou
n'a pas on n'a pas obtenu une
autorisation de la visite est ce que
vous avez pu déborder un petit peu du
cadre du wef organisé pour rencontrer
des soviétiques discuter avec eux de
voir le problème de la langue
pratiquement aucun de nous parler russe
et ensuite nous avons essayé de parler
français pratiquement n'avons rencontré
personne et anglais quelques-uns et on
avait presque l'impression qu'ils ne
cherchent pas trop à parler en
particulier nous avons visité un camp de
jeunesse communiste qui étaient des
étudiants des étudiants de l'université
fief finalement nous n'avons pas pu nous
n'avons pratiquement pas rencontrer des
étudiants désirant parlait aussi bien en
français qu'en anglais mais dans quelle
sorte de soviétiques avaient grand coup
en contre et surtout nous avons
rencontré tout d'abord des guides de
l'hymne touristes
ensuite nous avons rencontré quelques
vieilles personnes qui dans leur
jeunesse avait fait des séjours en
france où avait parlé en français le
marchand de
près et puis ensuite enfin je crois qu
est ce qu une chose qui existe en urss
et qui est connue plus ou moins on se
fait aborder dans les rues par des
personnes qui cherchent à vous achetez
votre pantalon ou votre remise à
condition qu'elle soit en me l'ont
ces personnes là enfin nous n'avons eu
aucun contact il faut absolument pas
négliger l'effort considérable que fait
ce pays
et l'esprit de la de l'interview était à
s'orienter par certaines personnes qui
est qu'ils n'ont vu que des aspects
négatifs de du pays et il ya des aspects
qui sont certainement très positif par
exemple mais par exemple
c'est la première fois que ben enfin
personnellement je viens l'urss et et
d'après certains journaux occidentaux je
me suis aperçue qu'il y à certaines
orientations dans la presse occidentale
il y a incontestablement un progrès
considérable et il ne faut absolument
pas le contester il est des exemples
précis plus concret peut-être je ne sais
pas on a par exemple dit qu' il n'y
avait que le trafic automobile n'était
pas énorme or je m'aperçois
naturellement il correspond actuellement
pas au niveau de la circulation qui
existent en occident c'est certain mais
tout de même il ya des voitures
la durée du contrat qu il ya des ongs
aleya géant la vie des embouteillages et
qui est
alors finalement peu de temps porter un
jugement sur l'urssaf est un voyage
comme celui ci trois semaines
c'est pas la peine d'insister en trois
semaines pour essayer vraiment apprécié
en trois semaines il n'est pas facile de
comprendre un pays c'est vrai en union
soviétique plus qu'ailleurs peut-être
quand on est touriste beaucoup de
questions restent sans réponse peut-être
notre guide de l'hymne touristes nous
aidera tél
aimez vous qu'on vous pose des questions
comment mais vous qu'on vous pose des
questions a certainement voilà ce que
les interprètes politiques aiment
beaucoup quand on nous pose des
questions de l'heure c'est très dur mais
on voit qu'on s'intéresse à notre pays
moi j'aime bien ça et si on vous demande
par exemple pourquoi ne peut continuer
ne peut-on pas sortir le dessin tout
seul en voiture car de touristes
étrangers qui vous est 10 heures
les touristes qui vient essayer le
voyeur à genoux il ya les vestiaires de
saeed de sel par anti guerre en voiture
parce que nous par exemple nous avons
une voiture nous avons essayé d'aller
faire un petit tour or d'odessa c'est
une autre chose quand les touristes bien
et si chez nous ils ont un petit air air
x est si vous êtes abonné au dessin
alors dans les papiers dans les bouches
cet écrit que vous êtes arrivé à odessa
vous avez divisés à odessa et vous
restez au décès si vous voulez aller à
que ailleurs vous devez avoir les
documents pour aller ailleurs parce que
les membres de l'ordre et sortent du
rang de service et si cette ville entre
d'un itinéraire de vingt touristes
adorent ces mots clés sur les prononcent
mais c'est justement pourquoi ces gens
parce que je voulais savoir pourquoi je
suis obligée d'avoir prévu dans mon
itinéraire que j'irai à tel endroit si
j'ai envie d'aller faire un tour dans un
petit village des environs de l'essonne
il existe un itinéraire spécial pour les
touristes étrangers est tout simple
prévue pour une autre loi notre pays
c'est les règles intérieures de notre
pays c'est comme ça que nous avons fait
les tumeurs dans notre pays parce que
nous ne voulons pas que cette ville
certains objets ne prend des
industriels politiques seront visitées
par les étrangers parce qu'il ya des cas
quand les touristes étrangers s'étaient
exemple avec de touriste pour l'heure
des braves les touristes de l'allemagne
occidentale quand il y avait les cheveux
le cas quand il arrivait avec les idées
prévu préparé qui n'était pas à point de
vue du tout les idées de tout risque oui
je te comprends qu'on empêche d'aller
voir un lieu stratégique mais comment
vous allez voir un village si j'en ai
envie mais s'il vous plaît en visite du
site le kolkhoze moi je dis que pour les
étrangers pour tous les touristes on ne
sait pas ce que les étrangers et aux
listes apporte ce qu'ils ont dans leur
âme
qu'est ce qu'on appelle les touristes
sauvage
achats non
j'ai entendu dans les conversations
entre deux guides
et tous les stages ce sont les touristes
sont plutôt les jeunes qui ne veulent
pas acheter le bon de ce jour
moi par exemple quand j'étais étudiante
je préférais aussi d'aller en crimée
caucase mais surtout près de dessin pour
camper
on a une tente on s'est reposé bord de
la mer il y avait des personnes autour
fait ce qu'on veut alors c'est
tranquille c'est bon
passer ça va je pars spill
il ya reste seul parce qu'ils
font ce qu'ils veulent ça
c'est justement ce que ce soit de les
touristes étrangers
[Musique]